we have unhelpful advice see at the end
of our show we do an unhealthy okay
let's do it let's knock it out unhealth
advice with bobby klyla
and andrew i'm a 20 year old 28 year old
man who has always suffered from
premature ejaculation
it started when i was 15 and instead of
trying to receive help or trying to
learn about it
i continued to be embarrassed kept it to
myself and got really good at the
post-acquittal apology
recently after reading great sex by
michael casselman i began practicing
better masturbation techniques and
better breathing but it still happens
especially the first few times i'm with
the lady
and the comfort level isn't there we're
talking like 5 to 12 seconds
i like to think i have a good
foundational relationship with women due
to a great upbringing with my mom and
sister
but i find myself nervous to talk with
women because i figure that the best
case scenarios lead me to an
embarrassing future moment while naked
and vulnerable
so sometimes i get nervous to pursue
question is
what do you recommend i say to the lady
when the inevitable occurs
do i make a joke afterwards find a way
to bring it up beforehand
and have you ever gone through this and
have tips on how to improve stamina
okay i don't know what it is what do you
mean what is it
premature too quickly five to twelve
seconds so he nuts right away
yeah all right so you it's basically if
you look at my dick
this fyi okay you'll see a purple heart
really because i've been through some
wars wow wow
okay there's shrapnel in it oh boy oh
yeah
oh boy yeah yeah it's been through some
wars right because i beat it to [ __ ]
pieces
that's how you prepared it yeah yeah
right so it's like you know i mean
it's either do it that way you just you
just watch a lot of porn
let's what about what about just jerk
within he was a two-pump chump really
loved him a lot
but what he was really really really
good at was foreplay
because he has to be he has to it's like
you if you
you gotta just get her there first so
you have no guilt or no shame about
nutting in two seconds now here's a
question did he did you ever try to go
on top to start so he's not really
in control that's another thing i think
it mattered for him it was just
like the also i one of the guys that i
hooked up with in the philippines
this guy like nutted on my kneecap he
touched my legs
and he nutted before there was any type
of real four player
oh wow he was like that's like
complimentary legs
so now is there a part of you you're
obviously unsatisfied but is there a
part that's like
super complimented by that no because i
feel as though at that point like a
breeze could get him there ah so it's
it's it's a dysfunction it's not yeah
and then what he said afterwards just
really put me off
what was it i remember saying like oh
like are you hungry there's this really
delicious place next door and i was
trying to be nice because the guy
i mean i thought that he would be
ashamed about it yeah but clearly he
wasn't and
what he said he's like i eat to live i
don't live to eat
i was like i gotta get out of here yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but speaking of eating it's it's it it
reminds me
of when i eat with you in jewels what
happens so you guys eat really quickly
we do because we were poor for so long
i eat slowly because i grew up in a
country club you know
i grew up in a country club so i'll do
the thing right once you know i'll
slowly you know slice into whatever i'm
eating right i'll look at it
right yeah i'll save her savoriness i
love savoring
you know i'll do the savory
and so and they're already done they're
out they're uh you're right so what i
want to do is
like this man right i wanna you know um
when i'm almost done eating then you can
start
yeah that's basically the same logic
yeah that's the same logic yeah yeah
yeah i think and also [ __ ] uglier girls
too
oh i don't think that maybe he's like
maybe yes
like i mean just cry yeah right like
just try it maybe that's possible it's
possible that you're
sleeping with such attractive women like
these unbelievably beautiful women that
like you can't control yourself and then
maybe if
you slept with a girl that you were less
attracted to for whatever reason like
maybe that would help you
if i was a guy i'd for sure be him i
i it doesn't it takes me nothing to come
it takes me nothing a breeze can get me
there
really i i come in my sleep while i'm
dreaming
well that must feel good bobby yeah but
it's nothing
i don't know what she's thinking about
she's dreaming but i'd be him i'd exact
i know it
maybe my dad was a you know premature
major ejaculation oh you have it in you
got your dad's dna
maybe your dad's coming that's really
sad
i came on i came on an elevator button
once oh yeah
oh god i'm sorry what i i came on an
elevator i never told this
you were jerking off no okay so i was
at a club yeah any many many years ago
you went clubbing babe
no at a comedy club oh i was performing
okay and i made out with a girl
in the elevator okay right coming down
okay she was leaving and as the elevator
closed
i jerked off onto the [ __ ] buttons of
the phone i mean i love that
i love that i felt bad for whoever was
going to press i want to know what club
it is
it was in um tampa
improv or tampa improv not side
splitters or whatever no
okay uh how do you know about science
lutheran arts well i i do comedy
professional comedian guys yeah uh
do you like tampo improv i i like the
tampa improv yeah yeah
it's a tough room for me really yeah oh
because the ceilings are just huge
are there clubs that you don't like